et comment allez vous vous êtes ici pour
votre petite dose d'horreur alors c'est
parti
ouais j'ai failli refaire l'erreur de la
dernière fois j'avais un fois les gars
qui vous a fait plus peur que les
histoires de la vidéo c'est l'intro qui
était trop courte vous vous en êtes pas
remis alors je sais qu'après autant de
vidéos autant d'années on s'aime mais
parfois on n'est pas là pour juste
discuté il ya des histoires qui
attendent d'être racontée merde alors
aujourd'hui comme d'hab' trois histoires
comme d'alger s'est trouvé des
mécaniques sympathie j'espère qu'elle
vous plairont il ya une histoire qui se
passe dans des toilettes publiques tient
c'est arrivé qu'une seule fois en quoi
20 30 sera d'horreur donc je pense que
l'occasion d'y refaire un seau et
pourquoi je parle comme toi ne les
tiennent j'en ai aucune idée
on essaie avec lauren de trouver des
histoires qui change de celle qu on m'a
déjà raconté je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
mission est accomplie est ce qu'on est
bon pour la tronche sais pas combien de
fois la durée ce que est ce que ça vous
a suffi ce qu'on peut passer aux
histoires la première histoire et pas
celle d'une personne mais d'un couple
constance et julien c'est une histoire
qui leur est arrivé en 2012 et j'espère
qu'ils sont encore en sommes voilà ça me
ferait chaud au coeur à l'époque
constance à 20 ans on est mercredi soir
et elle décide d'aller au restaurant
avec son petit ami
il décide d'aller à un restaurant qui a
moins de cinq minutes en voiture de
l'appartement de julien c'est un
restaurant qui est située dans une ville
universitaire mais qui est passé près du
campus pour attirer beaucoup de monde et
ce soir-là il pleut donc le peu
d'étudiants qu'on aurait pu aller là-bas
n'iront pas parce que plus égale flemme
et conscience et julien ça ils en sont
ravis parce qu'ils adorent les endroits
calmes il n'y a pas beaucoup de monde
voire personnes alors ni une ni deux ça
fait longtemps ça ne voulait pas entendu
et près de la voiture et les hiboux le
restaurant est tout à fait normal c'est
une chaîne en plus de ça c'est assez
rassurant et ce jour là il ya une promo
aujourd'hui nous vous offrons une tarte
si vous dépensez plus de 20 $ et vous
connaissez le pouvoir du marketing même
site en voulait pas de cet art tu
l'apprends ils arrivent sur place aux
alentours de 21h ils sont pas sûrs que
le service soit encore ouvert fin
peut-être les cuisines sont fermés et
demande donc à la première serveuse
qu'ils aperçoivent et elle leur répond
que si les cuisines ferme à minuit dans
ce restaurant ya qu une seule serveuse
c'est l école est venu vers lui pour
prendre leurs commandes
elle s'est présentée comme s'appelant
salies et à partir de là changement
d'ambiance constance elle aime pas trop
salie et la manière dont elle a dit son
nom donne l'impression à constance
qu'elle a menti sur son moins bon quand
bien même elle a menti on s'en fout
c'est une serveuse ses lapins vite
donner son vrai nom quel est le problème
bref les minutes passent julien et
constance discutent tranquillement et
consorts c'est quand même un peu sur ses
gardes
peu de temps après sally vient leur
donner leur plein est là elle va faire
un peu la discussion saly où je vous ai
jamais vu avant vous êtes nouveau
vous venez du campus qui est pas loin
d'ici alors faut comprendre qu'en france
c'est plutôt rare qu'un
avoir une serveuse tape à ce point la
discussion mais aux états unis dans leur
culture ils ont le pourboire et ça peut
représenter à la fin du mois un énorme
pourcentage des revenus des serveurs
voir la part principale de leurs revenus
de du coup y'a plein de serveurs et
serveuses qui vont discuter plus que la
normale pour essayer de créer du lien
dans le but d'obtenir un pourboire quand
tu pars en plus ce soir là il n'y a pas
d'autres clients il n'y a pas d'autres
serveurs elle est seule en salle elle
doit probablement bien se faire chier
c'est pour ça qu'elle veut discuter
constance et julien finissent leurs
plats tranquillement et devinez quoi ils
ont accès à la tarte gratuite salle y
prend donc leurs commandes de tarte
gratuite et puis elle leur dit ce soir
il pleut énormément c'est très dangereux
de conduire avec un temps pareil si
j'étais vous je resterai un peu plus
longtemps ici évidemment constance
n'aime pas trop ça depuis le début elle
inflige bizarre avec sally et que sally
veuille les retenir ici c'est pas normal
à ses yeux
bref quelques minutes plus tard sali le
ramène de parts de tartes alors
mauvaises surprises d'après constance la
tarte à un goût ignoble constant
surprend quand même quelques bouchées
elle sait même pas pourquoi moi
j'aimerais lui dire que c'est parce que
la tarte est gratuit donc forcément tu
as envie de taper dedans et puis en
tournant la tête
elle croise le regard de la serveuse qui
est situé à l'arrière du restaurant aux
côtés d'un homme et ses deux personnes
en se rendant compte que constance les
regarde
arrête de la fixer et rentre dans la
cuisine et c'est la constance se dit
soit je suis en train de faire le plus
gros coup de paranoïa de toute ma vie
soit il se passe vraiment un truc
bizarre dans ce restaurant et j'ai un
[ __ ] d'instinct et il faut que je me
casse maintenant et c'est ce qu'elle va
faire
elle regarde julien elle lui dit on part
maintenant julien gros beau gosse en
voyant que constance et les ampoules
stress il pose aucune question il se
lève il met un billet de 50 dollars sur
la table prend constance par le bras et
ils partent ils arrivent dans leur
voiture y démarrer commence à prendre la
route
et plus le temps passe plus m a rigolé
de la situation en se disant [ __ ] on a
réagi de manière très excessive là on
est on est peut-être un peu tendu en ce
moment peut-être que le mec à côté de
salies nous regarder mal parce que c'est
le cuistot et qu'il était saoul et de
devoir rester au restaurant à cause de
seulement deux clients et peut-être
qu'elle est là juste tout donner pour
avoir un pourboire et qu'elle n'était
pas méchante du tout bref les deux sont
un peu con d'avoir jugé si vite les deux
personnes sans se dire que peut-être les
apparences sont trompeuses et que
peut-être qu'au fond il se faisait des
idées est là
blackout constant se souvient de rire de
la situation avec julien dans la voiture
et la seconde d'après elle se souvient
s'être réveillée en frissonnant dans son
lit dans son appartement tout ce qui
s'est passé entre les deux elle a
complètement oublié
à son réveil elle voit son petit ami
allongé dans le lit complètement habillé
et trempé constance précise qu' un black
out ça ne lui est jamais arrivé ni à
elle ni à julien et que ce soir là il
avait même pas bu une goutte d'alcool et
détail qui a son importance
souvenez-vous le restaurant est à
seulement 5 minutes de voiture de chez
julien ça veut dire que s'il était resté
deux minutes de plus dans ce restaurant
c'est là bas qu'ils se seraient évanouis
et où il serait réveillé ça on n'en sait
rien ils en sont donc arrivés à la
conclusion suivante il y avait quelque
chose dans cette tarte qui a été
volontairement mais ici pour qu'il
s'évanouisse tête du ghb peut-être une
autre drogue tête une autre saloperie
mais heureusement constance a eu de
l'instinct et c'est en voiture que le
black out a commencé et pas dans le
restaurant alors les biens en soirée en
boîte en club en tout ce que vous voulez
en public au-delà des inconnus faut
faire super gaffe à votre verre pour que
personne église quoi que ce soit mais
[ __ ] si faut ce méfier d'une tarte au
restaurant où est ce qu'on va là aussi
constance du lendemain et la tchèque et
le site web du restaurant est
apparemment leurs heures d'ouverture
c'est 7 heures à 20 heures
du coup pourquoi en arrivant à 21h on
leur a dit qu'il n'y a pas de souci pour
être servi il est temps de passer à la
deuxième histoire la deuxième histoire
c'est celle de m'a dit m'a dit elle vit
dans le nebraska et elles adorent se
retrouver seul dans sa voiture avec
juste la nature autour d'elle personne
sur la route d'ailleurs pour éviter
qu'ils les gens sur la route
elle fait souvent des trajets de nuit et
depuis 4 5 ans elle a eu zéro problème
sauf la nuit passé ce soir là elle est
chez elle avec son mec ça va pas trop
dans sa tête hamadi elle repense à x
problèmes dont elle veut pas parler elle
explique à son copain qu'elle va faire
un peu de route pour s'aérer l'esprit
elle va d'abord faire le tour de sa
ville pendant une trentaine de minutes
et puis elle décide d'emprunter une
autoroute plus au nord et qui est plutôt
sombre et sinueuse
elle est donc sur cette autoroute à 120
km/heure elle fait attention dans les
virages a potentiellement acer qui
traversait la route
elle observe l'obscurité autour d'elle
les champs de maïs les arbres sans
feuilles
on est vraiment au début d'un film
d'horreur et elle se fait elle même
cette réflexion dans la voiture on est
aux alentours de 23 heures et à 10
minutes de maddie à un rond point
qu'elle compte utiliser pour faire demi
tour et prendre l'autoroute dans l'autre
sens direction chez elle m'a dit
empreint de la sortie est là elle
aperçoit au loin un véhicule avec ses
warnings allumés et ce véhicule est
incliné entre la chaussée et la route
comme s'il avait dû s'arrêter dans la
précipitation et à côté de la chaussée
on est sur une forêt donc des arbres des
arbustes etc
en se rapprochant elle voit que la
portière que
conducteur est grande ouverte et en
ralentissant elle aperçoit à l'intérieur
de la portière ce qui ressemble
fortement à du sang elle regarde aux
alentours il ya aucune autre voiture ou
aucune autre personne elle est seule
elle a un très bon réflexe elle prend
son téléphone elle regarde cla du réseau
pour contacter les secours mais ya rien
voici une situation de merde
elle est donc très méfiante mais a quand
même une petite partie d'elle qui se dit
là il ya quand même quelqu'un qui a
peut-être eu un accident qui est
peut-être vraiment dans la merde et il a
besoin de mon aide
mady décide donc de s'arrêter à côté de
la voiture immobilisée et baissé sa
vitre côté passager et elle demande s'il
ya quelqu'un et si tout va bien
aucune réponse elle se dit que peut-être
que la personne s'est évanoui
un peu plus loin mais que quoi qu'il en
soit elle elle ne doit pas sortir de sa
voiture qui est sa seule protection
elle se dit alors que tout ce qu'elle
peut faire c'est de re manifester sa
présence et s'il n'ya pas de réponse
elle ira plus loin avec sa voiture là où
il ya du réseau pour appeler les secours
et donner la position de la voiture
immobilisée
écoutez moi bien elle est méga smart
c'est vraiment ouf
après un long silence les buissons à
côté de la voiture remue elle distingue
une silhouette entre les arbres et une
voix grave lui répond madier soulager la
personne qui a eu l'accident est
consciente et c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle remarque trois choses presque
simultanément la première elle réalise
qu'il ya aucun dégâts au niveau de la
voiture tous les pare chocs sont intacts
le pare brise est intacte aucune rayure
rien deuxièmement en regardant dans son
rétroviseur côté passager elle distingue
une silhouette qui sort de derrière la
voiture immobilisée et qui se dirige
rapidement vers la sienne et
troisièmement cette même personne ne
présente aucune blessure aucune trace de
sang et dans sa main il distingue un
objet plutôt non comme un pied de biche
en seulement quelques secondes mady
réalise qu'elle est probablement dans un
guet-apens
hélas elle met pied au plancher dans son
accélération sa fenêtre côté passager
est toujours ouverte et elle entend la
voix grave qu'elle a déjà entendu une
première fois lui hurler dessus
elle distingue pas un mot de ce que la
personne dit mais elle en est sûre ça
pue autour de cette voiture et elle se
casse il s'agissait d'un guet-apens et
si elle sortait de sa voiture elle sait
pas ce qui lui serait arrivé et surtout
elle aurait pu prévenir personne puisque
avait pas de réseau à cet endroit là
l'histoire finit bien les mecs n'ont pas
pris en chasse m'a dit elle a pu
atteindre rapidement le parking d'un
centre commercial sur lequel avait
beaucoup de voitures elle a appelé la
police et son copain ils sont tous venus
la chercher il envoyait une patrouille
pour essayer de trouver les mecs étaient
mobilisés au milieu de la route
en arrivant sur les lieux la voiture
n'était plus là les deux mecs avaient
disparu et ça encore une fois c'est un
truc qui arrive beaucoup les guet-apens
c'est horrible et pas forcément sur la
route on l'a déjà vu dans d'autres et
dorin il ya des histoires où c'est des
mecs qui peuvent stocker chez toi
battent à coup de pression en mode vie
d'hier mais des isp à 6 alors que dalle
et ses mécaniques que je trouve horrible
quoi profiter du fait que la personne en
face baisse ses proches
parce qu'elle pense que tu as besoin
dead et d'en profiter à mauvais escient
je trouve ça horrible
les mecs c'est des mousses 3 alors tout
ça vous avez à l'a380 l'histoire de
coralie c'est la fameuse histoire qui se
passe dans des toilettes publiques
c'est une histoire qui arrivait à
coralie sept ans avant qu'elle nous la
raconte quand elle avait encore 14 ans
elle habitait dans un quartier pas où
vous dire qu'il y avait un cinéma pas
ouf
et en plus d'être pas très cher c'est un
vieux cinéma où le staff s'en fout un
peu des règles et du coup il est laissé
aller voir le film qu'elle voulait même
les film interdit aux moins de 16 ou 18
ans le rêve quand tu es jeune sans elle
ils vont à 5 ans arrivant elle achète
des petits snacks et puis avant d'aller
dans la salle de projection coralie elle
a envie d'aller aux toilettes
on est dans une toute petite ville aux
etats-unis le cinéma est très mal
entretenu genre ces crabes ya qu un seul
employé chargé de l'entretien il en a un
peu rien à [ __ ] vu le peu de clients
pierre du coup c'est encore plus
dégueulasse puisque vous imaginez bref
coralie arrive dans les toilettes des
filles
en arrivant il ya aucun bruit elle pense
donc qu'elle est seule ce qui la rassure
elle a fait un peu bad est à la fois moi
j'avoue j'ai un peu comme coralie les
lieux publics où il ya personne ça me
fait trop peur j'ai l'argent je vais
prendre une embuscade
coralie instinctivement elle veut aller
dans la cabine la plus proche de la
porte d'entrée des toilettes mais en
poussant la porte elle voit que c'est
vraiment dégueu elle aperçoit ce qui
semble être du sang de règles du coup
elle se dit bon un peu abusé là je vais
aller voir l'autre cabine elle l'ouvré
bingo c'est moins crade qu'avant donc
elle se pose dans celle ci et c'est là
que commence le calvaire
coralie elle entend quelqu'un rire
peut-être quelqu'un qui est dans l'une
des quatre cabines un peu plus loin et
qu'elle avait pas entendu avant mais
quand même c'est plutôt rare d'entendre
des gens se taper des barres dans les
toilettes publiques du coup elle est un
peu dans mal de nouvelles en temps un
rire mais cette fois c'est pas un rire
c'est vraiment une grosse barre coralie
elle est toujours sur les toilettes et
elle se dit je veux devenir invisible je
pense comme ce serait le cas pour nous
tous et la chorale y entend la porte de
la cabine en face de la sienne s'ouvrir
et puis plus rien aucun bruit de pas les
seconds parce qu'au rallye a le coeur
qui bat de 100 à l'heure et après
quelques secondes que rallye sous la
porte elle voit apparaître des
chaussures et ses chaussures c'est un
modèle un peu enfantin coralie elle se
dit ah mais ça explique tout c'est un
enfant qui était aux toilettes où le
rire d'où le fait d'ouvrir la porte et
de rester immobile allez savoir ce qui
se passe dans la tête d'un enfant dans
les toilettes publiques
et puis après quelques secondes à
regarder les chaussures elle se dit mais
son grande des chaussures placer un
modèle d'enfants mais la cdu 42 et c'est
à peu près au même moment qu'elle entend
la personne gratter compte la porte des
toilettes
coralie elle a un très bon réflexe et
qu'elle prend ses jambes autour de ses
bras elle est assise sur les toilettes
comme ça de manière à passer inaperçu si
jamais la personne de l'autre côté de la
porte
regarde en dessous la porte et d'un coup
c'est plus des chaussures qu'elle boit
cette personne mais un bras
sous la porte des toilettes de corani
évidemment elle elle se met à pleurer
elle envoie des sms à ses amis pour
qu'ils viennent l'aider sauf que comme
ils sont dans la salle de projection bas
personne et sur son téléphone et après
un moment c'en est trop coralie elle
décide d'écraser de toutes ses forces la
main de la personne avec son pied
immédiatement à la personne sort son
bras de la cabine et commence à gêner
coralie est tétanisée et la personne est
toujours juste en face de sa cabine elle
peut pas sortir peu à peu le gémissement
cesse-t-on et le silence revient dans
les toilettes
long silence rompu par un ou sa plume
apport coralie hurle elle hurlé pendant
qu'elles eurent la personne de l'autre
côté de la porte dit plein de trucs et
d'un coup la personne arrête de parler
coralie arêtes du relais elle va rester
quinze minutes ici seuls en boule sur
ces toilettes sans ouvrir la porte par
peur que la personne soit encore de
l'autre côté à l'attendre quinze minutes
plus tard elle entend la porte des
toilettes s'ouvrir et là elle se dit bon
bah soit c'est la personne qui était là
qui vient de partir soit c'est quelqu'un
qui vient de rentrer et qui va pouvoir
m'aider
elle ouvre donc le verrou de sa cabine
et soulagement il y a plus personne dans
les toilettes et la personne qui vient
d'ouvrir la porte des toilettes c'est la
fille de l'accueil du cinéma qui s'est
ramené parce qu'elle a vu coralie
rentrée aux toilettes il ya 20 minutes
mais pas sortir et donc elle est venue
voir si tout allait bien le manager est
arrivé sur les lieux il a inspecté
chaque cabine il n'a rien trouvé aucune
trace de la vieille dame qui était la
plus tôt et donc ils ont rien pu faire
pour coralie à part lui dire est ce que
tu es sûr que c'est vraiment arrivé ce
que tu racontes parce qu'on a trouvé
personne bref la vieille dame des
toilettes j'espère ne jamais te croiser
sa santé risque pas de m'arriver moi je
vais jamais dans des toilettes où il ya
le truc sous la porte là c'est une peur
de collégiens mec
écoutez c'est la fin de ce serait dur
j'espère qu'il vous a plu c'était 3
excellente histoire j'aime beaucoup
celle ci j'espère que ce serait l'erreur
ont pour effet de vous pousser à croire
en vos instincts et pas de vous pousser
à être parano et sur méfiance est
vraiment pas le but même si au fond
c'est un peu ce qui nous arrive - y
compris croyez moi moi même aux
premières loges parce qu'on en ligne ou
des histoires avant de raconter trois
mersen regarder a très vite portez vous
bien je faire des coucous de la main
maintenant régulièrement